what do you think this is I mean I look
like maybe seaweed or it definitely
looks like something from the sea like a
okay well it's interesting mathematical
seaweed and I can explain exactly how we
made that image because to me that image
is one of the most mind-blowing pictures
illustrations of very simple math ideas
so it is and we're going to get their
comments conjecture
I know you've done videos on the classic
injector but here is your quick or
refresher with a take a number and we
can do two things to this number
depending on its parity that's why
there's others even if it's even we're
going to divide by two and if it's odd
we're going to multiply by three so
triple it and add one which we're going
to make it even which will then make it
even and then we know we do believe in
numbers that we divide them by two let's
say start with say 13 so 13 is odd so
multiplied by three and add one so 13
will go to 39 or on 40 goes to 40 okay
even they divide that by 2 goes to 20
okay we divide that by 2 goes to 10
again divided by 2 goes to 5 odd
multiplied by 3 15 add 1 16 they go 16
and then look 16 - 8 - 4 - 2 - 1 the
conjecture made by Collett is that every
number that you choose is eventually
going to go down to number 2 1 so some
of them are going to go all over the
place but eventually everything's going
to want as a conjecture which is think
is true but we can't prove it and one of
the reasons why the conjecture is one of
the most famous unsolved problems in
math is that we appear to be nowhere
close to a solution I know a close at
all people believe that whole new bits
of math need to be invented before we
can do this and it's one of the few
things that is so simple to state yet
still so complicated it's got the sort
of mythical status now advanced
mathematicians and what I want to do is
show how Edwin Harris who is Masterson
who I work with has created this amazing
image that illustrates what's going on
with Carl Apps and when he first showed
it to me I was like blown away I've got
at 13 and then a line like that actually
already what people do is you've build
this big tree because eventually things
are going to have to get to one so if
they get to one they're going to have to
come from two then they're going to have
to come down from four and so you can
build this big tree what you see with
the tree is that you've got all these
branches coming down
like this you know and get enter and
going into it
and normally when you see this done
they're done to try and maximize the
sort of logic of how it's done
so the distance will be the same they'll
be done so it like kind of looks looks
good on the page and it looks like
something in a math textbook but
actually what Edmunds has done is to
make it so it's interesting to look at
but so that you get more of an insight
about why this whole problem is
interesting imagine if you start at the
bottom either going to go up to an odd
number or an even number if we're
getting to an even number then it's
going to slightly go off in that
direction if it's going to an odd number
it's going to slightly in that direction
clockwise or anticlockwise
yeah anti-clockwise for odd and
clockwise for even and then you get the
tree becomes this this is something
already a starting look a bit
interesting and then obviously we're not
that interested in the individual
numbers we're interested in sort of the
overall feel he gets rid of the numbers
and sort of exhibiting like the lines
between them how the lines relate and so
the thickens them out to make them look
like branches and then carried it on
until he includes every number less than
10,000 you end up with hundreds of
branches and then looks like that
it is so messy it's so disorderly we've
seen this incredibly simple thing
divided by 2 or x 3 ad1 and then divided
by 2
who would have thought that you'd get
this thing here but it looks organic
braylee you were saying looks like
something definitely floating the bottom
of the sea so you've got two things
going on there
you've got the nature of the growth then
you've also got the color of the wind
eNOS over the waves and to think that
something so natural looking something
so organic something so complicated
comes from something so simple this to
me is the best way to explain a kind of
complicated nature of the Collinson
ginger is what it's doing is you're
looking at anything oh my god Babbage
complicated thing oh now I understand
why no one's got a clue
[Music]
if you've enjoyed this video and want to
dig even deeper into the world of
knowledge why not check out the great
courses plus they've got an extensive
collection of videos presented by world
experts in all sorts of fields from
number theory to art history and that's
a nice mixture of what you've just been
watching here you can even learn to read
ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs and it's
bit of an Egypt nut that's a topic that
fascinates me somewhat unlimited access
to the full catalogue of videos costs
14.99 a month but you can sign on for a
month-long free trial to see just how
good it is go to the great courses
plus.com slash numberphile to check them
out this is a great place to learn
amazing stuff from professional teachers
but at your own pace you can use your TV
tablet computer or phone that's the
great courses plus.com slash numberphile
and now thanks to them for supporting
this video